marcado por interrupciones y acusaciones
mútuas transcurrió el primer debate
presidencial
el mandatario reiteró que le
correspondía a él nominar al sucesor de
la fallecida ruth báder ginsburg
mientras que biden pidió esperar a que
haya un nuevo presidente para hacer la
confirmación argumentando el temor de
que la nominación de amy cón y barber
está hecha por trump ponga en peligro el
acceso a la salud asequible permitido
por el obama que en plena pandemia
en esta hora en la corte suprema-
tratando de deshacerse del obamacare lo
cual le quitaría a 20 millones de
personas su seguro de salud found in
insurance lo que derivó a la discusión
del cob y 19 estamos a semanas de una
vacuna estamos sí haciendo terapias
menos personas están muriendo cuando se
enferman muchos menos personas mueren
hemos hecho un gran trabajo lo único que
no ha sido mientras aunque eso es por
las noticias falsas sin importar lo que
uno les diga ellos dan mala prensa sus
noticias falsas
este es el mismo hombre que dijo que
para la pascua el virus desaparecería
cuando el clima caliente empezará
seguiría como
agro y a propósito tal vez podrías
inyectar un poco de cloro en tu brazo y
eso lo acabaría los impuestos de trump
tema que preveía sería clave tras las
revelaciones del 'new york times' según
las cuales no habría pagado nada en 11
años pasó casi de largo
usted nos dirá que tanto pagó en
impuestos en 2016 y 2017 millones de
dólares usted pagó millones de dólares
millones dólares millones de dólares y
usted podrá verlo y usted llegará a
verlo son responsabilizó a los
demócratas de los desmanes registrados
al margen de las protestas contra la
violencia policial el racismo
estructural mientras que el ex
vicepresidente evitó arremeter contra la
policía que esta protesta política
pacífica cuando van por la mitad de la
ciudad y acaban con las tiendas matan
gente por todas partes eso no es
protesta pacífica
es racista se mucho más sobre esto
el hecho es que hay insensibilidad
racial la gente tiene que ser consciente
de lo que sienten los demás de lo que
los insulta
entre las acusaciones de la noche trump
dijo que biden era un títere de la
izquierda radical a lo que el
exvicepresidente respondió que él era un
títere del presidente ruso vladimir
putin